20 hours at a remote balkan border
crossing in the winter is a lot of time
to think and dmitry bickoff has had a
lot to think about as he waits in a long
line of trucks to cross the border into
his home country of russia hauling a
load of goods to moscow yes yes madrid
bikov used to be in the russian military
he fears the war he thinks is wrong in
ukraine will see him back in uniform
drafted against his will minia mogute
they can send me even there but why do i
need it it's scary scary very scary
bickoff says he wishes there was no
borders and he could fly free like a
bird and global leaders would get along
as well as the multinational truckers in
this line do
what's the difference russian or not
russian we are all people despite
dimitri's dream there are borders and
they're complicated here in latvia which
is flanked by both belarus and russia
the impact of the war being felt here
too
this bella russian truck driver says
he's worried for his family in ukraine
there are divides within latvia over the
war 24 percent of latvians are ethnic
russians many of them live in the region
of latkal
in dalgaf pills we found a clear
generational split over putin's actions
lana says she's an example of that part
of an older generation with fond
memories of russia she's glad crimea was
taken and says ukraine antagonized
moscow but she can't talk to her
daughter about it because it's causing a
rift her daughter is part of the younger
generation who dislikes putin
the latvian government is looking for
reassurance from nato and western
leaders to send a message to putin that
collective defense is still intact
that's a message that prime minister
justin trudeau will deliver himself next
week when he travels here to latvia
donna mercedes stevenson thanks